the Billboard Music Awards what you
didn't see on TV plus Wiz Khalifa's son
goes ham at Taylor Swift's concert and
Katy Perry low-key shades Megan Markel
hello good people now that the dust has
settled on that regal royal wedding the
daily Denny is back to our regularly
scheduled program and I got a new denim
what do you think all right let me tell
you after last week and the wedding
Saturday your boy needed a pint but a
jolly good time was had by all
and we have lots more of Megan and
Harry's receptions more on that the
tearful tributes the late Princess Diana
and all the wedding fashion for you up
on et online.com and et's youtube
channel but you know speaking of fashion
Katy Perry had some thoughts about Miss
barkos gal on her big day take a look
did you guys think of the dress thoughts
on the dress I would have done one more
fitting
maybe tame that dress Kate Kate I'm
sorry I'm never not going to tell the
truth one more fitting Oh Katie the girl
just squashed the beef with Taylor Swift
and now she's coming for the new duchess
of sussex
what is she wrong but don't at me she
was still a vision okay I mean well the
artists at the Billboard Music Awards
were a sight of their own last night the
biggest stars in music rubbed elbows at
the BBM a's in las vegas but it was this
reunion backstage with Camila kibale and
normanni that i was not ready for but
former fifth harmony members together
again nearly a year and a half since
Camila quit 5h and might I say they
looked pretty happy to see each other
both performed at the show last night
which marked Normandy's first award show
performance as a solo artist and let me
tell you she slayed that you guys catch
her whipping her hair around and
sticking that landing and keeping her
wig intact this is some skill
nor money had me hollering at my TV but
no screams were as loud than from the
Army in the MGM Garden Arena losing
their collective minds over my boys BTS
the k-pop phenom performed their latest
single fake love and it was easily the
highlight of the night
[Music]
BTS army I know you saw what I saw
jungkook flashing his abs mid
choreography had you guys shook and they
did nail that performance but they
admitted to me just a couple of days
before the show they were nervous ah
honor its honor it's more nervous
because you know it's it's a world
premiere never expected like something
like this it's like beyond our dreams so
it'd be a lie affair like last nervous
we have so much more with BTS up on et's
YouTube channel I'm plugging our Channel
today Bob alright guys the fans help BTS
NAB their second Billboard Music Award
for top social artists and the Army is
only getting stronger because the boys
met so many famous fans last night
including miss Tyra Banks who served
face with BTS in the crowd they also met
the Backstreet Boys over the weekend
bringing together two of the biggest boy
band ever John Legend also posed with
the guys backstage John by the way was
taking some serious heat from wife
Chrissy Teigen last night who was at
home with their newborn baby miles and
jokes he was discussing for leaving them
at home after just having a baby I'm
with John by the way so make sure you
guys check that out tomorrow but among
the other stars who scored a photo with
BTS was none other than Taylor Swift who
posted this on her stories writing BTS
forever Taylor had a big night of her
own taking home top female artists and a
top-selling album but it was her show at
the Rose Bowl here in Los Angeles over
the weekend that had everybody talking I
was there but the first time I've ever
seen Taylor live and let me tell you
guys it was lit there were a lot of
celebs and famous friends who came to
see her of course
two even joined her on stage Choi Saban
and Taylor's bestie Selena Gomez
surprised the crowd on Saturday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that right there is apparently Taylor's
favorite Selena song and those two were
so sweet on each other and have the
whole stadium going crazy but I'm not
sure anyone had as much fun seeing
Taylor Swift and Wiz Khalifa and amber
Rose's son Sebastian the five-year-old
is apparently a huge swifty and even got
to meet his number-one backstage he
brought flowers guys with shared his son
going to hand during the show his job
was on the floor
he was scream singing and we are so here
for that cuteness but trust me he wasn't
the only one going off at the concert
uh am i swifty now yeah that's me in our
very own Katy Kraus who's actually
Taylor's number one fan and clearly we
had a blast in or maybe a bit
over-served but anyways such a fun
weekend glad to be back on the daily
Denny grind though so thanks so much for
watching check back here tomorrow for my
interview with mr. legend and I'll see
you guys then